- I'm gonna be honest,
since I started drinking
during the holidays,
they've gotten a lot easier.
- Aw, a little Grinch.
- This looks toxic.
- It's fruity smelling.
- It smells like Kool-Aid, man.
- Sours.
- Oh, yes. Ooh.
- Ooh. Yes!
- Is there even alcohol in this?
It just tastes like sugar and regret.
- By mistake, I'd probably
give this to a toddler.
- That would get you through your grandma
asking you a million times,
"Where's your man, baby?"
- If you're having a Christmas
party with all your friends,
maybe in a garage, maybe there's
a beer pong table around,
people are drinking these.
- Easily five out of five Grinches.
- Five out of five Grinches.
- [Quincy] Nice.
- Okay.
- Nice. Nice.
- How do you feel about that?
- You have to drink it like this.
- It looks so happy,
and then you taste it,
and it's like, mehh.
- Would you feel confident
ordering these for her?
- Yeah, as long as we split the check.
- You'd still break her heart?
- Yeah, man. It's me, man.
Hurt people are hurt people.
- Everyone has that sweet aunt
who turns into a (bleep)
monster after one of these.
- Two Mall Santas.
Because I don't think
it's a Christmas drink.
- It's not a Christmas drink.
- Ooh, this is pretty.
- This is some (bleep)
you found on Pinterest.
- Ooh.
- But it looks like Pepto Bismol.
- Tim Gunn, on Fashion Runway,
would give this a ten out of ten.
- Part of the ambiance of the drink
is part of the presentation, Matt.
- I am not arguing with you, Quincy.
- Yeah, but how do you do this?
Do you go like--
- Yeah, yeah. Um...
- Holy, hell. That one's strong.
That one's got the booze.
Are you gonna vomit right now?
Aim that way.
- Also, the mint reminds me of toothpaste,
so I feel like you could
drink this in the morning.
- Hey, should we talk about
your drinking in the morning?
- My fellow DGs would be like,
"Yeah, girl! Let's get drunk!"
It's just a bunch of
peppermint schnapps, you know?
- These drinks are so fun,
because I feel like this is something
you could probably make with your family.
It's like an activity.
- I would give it two Candy Canes.
- I'd give it three, because
the presentation was flawless.
- Two point five.
- The Singles Sangria.
- Ooh, this is what you
make with your girls.
- Feels like it's a mixer.
- Okay, a single lady deserves this drink.
- She does, because a lot of (bleep) boys
out there ruining lives.
- Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
- Mm, that's just wine with fruit in it.
- That is grown-up apple juice.
- When I drink it, I'm like,
"I'm not upset I'm single.
"I'm a sexy person."
- This is the Christmas morning drink.
- Oh, I can get on board with that.
- You don't wrap some presents with this,
you open some presents with this.
- Yes.